on overtime Michael why do you think
Trump was so provoked by your play okay
I saw your play I was in it a little bit
you ever you had guests in your play
it's fantastic made your Broadway debut
with me no I'd been on Broadway oh
that's right your honor but what Trump
did really go ape and was tweeting about
it what's the deal
I it's he waited till it was over so I
thought that show discipline didn't sell
any tickets for it I think I think
Trump's had a complicated relationship
with me the way that he's tweeted at me
in the past and danced around without
trying to get too angry because I am his
base yeah I am his demographic and I am
an angry middle-aged white guy from the
Midwest and then I then am his hopefully
worst enemy because be the battle is to
get as many of the people I grew up with
to go with me and not with him and we
lost Michigan by two votes per precinct
that's it
votes per precinct right and and so I'm
on a mission to make sure that doesn't
happen again not just in Michigan
well I got this I'm making a film about
him too right now he knows that and and
he he was on Fox News during the
election last year bragging about how he
and I have had dinner a couple of times
and Michael Moore he's a great guy he's
a great guy and he's and I'm like and
he's doing this because he's he knows
that that crossover where I live those 8
million Obama voters that voted for
Trump are also people who listen to me
and so we're in this battle for that
that group that will probably decide the
next election he needs to come after me
and and I say bring it on okay Donna how
can Democrats effectively battle against
gerrymandering Republican gerrymandering
we got to do what we did on Tuesday that
is we have to win gubernatorial races
next year there are 36 gubernatorial
races including here in California ten
to the top largest states if we want to
have veto power over bad maps that's
number one number two we need more
citizens legislators well yeah it's the
legislature remember the governor's can
veto that's why it was so important to
recapture that toe race so once again we
got to get out there we got a vote next
years the key because if we control
state houses in 2018 we'll be able to
reconfigure these districts in 2022 the
new saying is when they go low we go
local
Sara do you think a conservative
comedian would ever travel around the
country and meet people with radically
different beliefs like you did I don't
know I haven't met one oh yes you you
know conservative convenient no Dennis
Miller
yeah I actually he was one of the first
people who wanted to get on my show cuz
I interview people who have been changed
right and I didn't want to only you know
and but then I got a hard no I really
don't know him though I was a huge fan I
loved his black and white special yeah
can I say something another I know there
were any well I bet you I don't think
they liked the who the you know the guys
who the redneck toward that what do they
call it Jeff Foxworthy and what is it
but they're not political at all I don't
think I know if anything they know to
hide any political belief they like
happening if you scratch not Joe the
Plumber what sue yeah funny but I bet
you that they're conservative they're
you know this of course
oh I've slept with half of them
[Applause]
you're like foreign search words aren't
necessarily who you are it's just you
can't help it sometimes I do sexually I
think about him because it why because
like he like holds his breath when he
comes in there his wife will never let
you out of the house no I find him
abhorrent I don't like people who don't
look at the spirit of a thing like when
you decide to look at kneeling NFL
players and decide to not hear what
they're talking about and say it's about
the military that's [ __ ] right
somehow you got right from it's not
breathing during orgasm to kneeling for
the end sexual fantasy summers he
appears you know life is complicated
with absolute and it we don't know
everything Chris did something about the
Trump era make you want to revisit Bobby
Kennedy's life and legacy the opposite
he's a man of heart who had empathy for
people Trump can't express empathy with
a widow he doesn't have it Bobby we go
to the black community tonight that dr.
King was killed you did show empathy you
have to make yourself vulnerable you
can't just walk in and be tough with all
the armor on you got to walk in and let
yourself get hurt and he walked into it
the cops wouldn't come in with and he
had and I get the old tape do they know
yet
no he has to tell them that's right and
it were powerful and he basically was in
his awkwardness he was true and he ended
up saying things like we have to say a
prayer for our country and our people
but it was all like my brother was
killed by a white guy was awkward and
yet here he's telling people that the
greatest hero in history of their
history certainly and he's dead be
killed by white guy and a racist killing
and he had to tell them and he could do
it I know anybody else could do that in
light of all these sex scandals lately
what do you what do you say about the
Kennedys Bobby and Jack were both I
don't think it's doing I don't think I
don't think that's the important thing
okay it may not be the important thing
but people's lives they did they did
things back then domi in well okay just
tell me okay and I'll respond to each
point well I I think Kennedy certainly
was [ __ ] a mafia courier yeah that was
a problem Bobby's Bobby's going in for
rackets for three years of the rackets
committee he's going into the mob dub
labor guys is going up meanwhile the the
CIA's using Giancana to get Castro
meanwhile the old man's asking the
Giancana crowd to give money in West
Virginia what else it's hard to figure
out anything else
I mean Bobby's working against this
against the family on this he's working
against the CIA he's wearing as his
brother's girlfriend Jack Kenny's having
sex with Gen Con his girlfriend this is
a problem and and Bobby had to stop him
from doing it and maybe stop to see
Marilyn Monroe I think they both got in
there yeah I mean there's plenty of
books written about that I wanted to
write about his public life Ella quick
Bobby please do I was 11 years old my
parents took us to Washington just so we
could see the Capitol and yeah our
government and I was 11 and I got
separated from them in the Capitol
building and I went into the Senate
elevator by mistake and there's a man
reading a paper there and the door shuts
and the paper comes down and it's Bobby
Cal and I and he says what young man
what do you lost I said yes I've lost my
parents and and when the elevator doors
open on the next floor he took me to the
Capitol Police so that they could put
the radio out that there's a child
that's and then he stayed there with me
until my parents came talking to me
about Michigan and the Senators from
Michigan that's why you're a liberal
today
[Music]
all right
[Applause]
[Music]